[Music]
we were heading for a remote airstrip
and difficult landing for our pilots all
to get us into a place
Prince Harry keeps coming back to he's
visited lawanda National Park privately
for the past three years as president of
the African parks and you can see why
only half an hour into our journey and
we found a herd of elephants the need to
protect them from poachers one of the
reasons he believes it's us humans who
were killing the planet today's what I
think is more acceptable but everything
is in balance
we're the only thing that's putting
everything out of balance we are
literally driving ourselves here a
partnership between the British Army and
local Rangers is working to track and
stop the poachers with both sharing
their military skills and is working
with no elephants or rhino killed in the
past five years
Harry was also here to pay tribute to
Guardsman Matthew Tolbert who was killed
by an elephant in May while on patrol
for conservation and specifically
counter poaching his professionalism
personal courage was a hallmark of who
he was
in Malawi poverty and the high price of
ivory is one of the reasons for poaching
getting the local community to buy into
protecting their wildlife couldn't be
more important to hurry in everything
he's saying it's almost like you can
hear his father Prince Charles who over
the years has talked so much about
climate change and environmental damage
the thing is Harry can reach out to a
new generation on those issues that he
says are fundamental to our survival
speaking out so passionately means
Prince Harry has got his critics taking
us to a place that he cares so much
about it's an opportunity for him to
make the world wake up to how fragile
our planet really is Rhiannon Mills Sky
News in Malawi